[Musica]
[Applauso]
avere uno scopo nella vita è qualcosa di
estremamente
importante mi piacciono i temi leggeri
come avrete capito
per me ha un grande significato perché
ho sempre avuto il terrore di non avere
uno scopo vi ricordate la canzone di
ranieri quando scopre di non essere
servito a niente ecco quello è sempre
stata la mia la mia angoscia di non
poter lasciare il segno come leonardo
quando non c'è uno scopo
succedono anche cose brutte ero un bimbo
ero abbastanza mammone e dormivo nel
lettone con mia mamma mi piaceva a
dormire nel lettone con mia mamma e mi
ricordo che
qualche minuto prima che suonasse la
sveglia volte la sentivo piangere mia
mamma era una donna brillante parlava
sei lingue erano interprete lavorava a
livello internazionale però
viveva in un contesto lavorano in un
contesto in cui non veniva capita e in
qualche modo sentiva di dover andare
tutti i giorni a fare un lavoro che non
aveva nessuno scopo
oppure cosa è anche molto più brutte
mi è capitato almeno tre volte nella
vita di ricevere una telefonata
terribile mi fa tremare ancora adesso
quando ci penso
e quando ti dicono che una persona a te
cara si è tolta la vita
e io so che se avessi potuto
leggere quei segnali in qualche modo o
se avesse avuto l'esperienza che oggi
nell'aiutare le persone a trovare uno
scopo probabilmente
le cose sarebbero andate
sarebbero andate in modo diverso
vedete quando non è questo che voglio né
per la mia vita ne per la vita degli
altri perché quando non c'è scopo è come
se fossimo dal lato oscuro della forza
abbiamo addosso una una negatività una
pesantezza che non è solo un problema
nostro è un problema per le persone che
ci stanno vicino è un problema quando
torniamo e un problema per la tua
compagna il tuo compagno per i tuoi
bambini un problema per i tuoi amici e
quindi io ritengo che oggi si lavori su
tantissime cose sugli obiettivi sulle
strategie eccetera parola cosa
fondamentale è lo scopo che sostiene poi
tutto il resto
sono civiltà che di scopo ne sapevano
qualcosa e stonehenge ne è un esempio di
questo io ho lavorato tantissimo su
questo argomento e mi sono reso conto
che molte persone
trovano lo scopo e lo trovano a volte
negli hobby nel volontariato
in qualche passione questo è fantastico
questo è assolutamente bellissimo però
che cavolo passiamo 90 mila ore in media
della nostra vita
sul luogo del lavoro è possibile che io
debba passare 90.000 ora da una parte e
poi trovare lo scopo quando rientra a
casa a fare il mio hobby e quindi lì mi
sono convinto che aiutare le persone a
trasformare il lavoro in un qualcosa che
permetta di portare valore verso fuori è
quello che può fare veramente la
differenza è quello che può cambiare la
nostra vita la vita dei nostri cari e su
scala più grande può veramente impattare
in modo importante sul mondo
è veramente un qualcosa che
è veramente un qualcosa che in qualche
modo ci tocca nel profondo
se il lavoro è espressione del sé
noi lasciamo il nostro segno tutti
cerchiamo più denaro e più successo però
se ci pensate il denaro il successo non
possono essere lo scopo del lavoro sono
la conseguenza sono la conseguenza di
che cosa sono la conseguenza del valore
che io andando al lavoro porto nel mondo
nel mondo lì fuori quello che serve un
rovesciamento completo di paradigma voi
pensate oggi la cultura dominante sul
lavoro io mi ricordo una registrazione
di quando ero lino ascoltato che mamma
un certo punto dice papà al lavoro
perché deve portare a casa i soldini per
vivere che idea si fa un bambino del
significato del lavoro
in un mondo in cui il significato del
lavoro il procacciamento di denaro non
possiamo fare altro che uscire i
miliardi di persone tutte le mattine ad
andare a fare che cosa quello che fanno
i cercatori d'oro a raccattare la nostra
piccola fettina di denaro piccolo grande
che sia ma sicuramente con il coltello
tra i denti perché una risorsa che ci
dobbiamo spartire immaginatevi invece
una società organizzata in modo
esattamente
rovesciato cioè in cui veniamo educati e
cresciuti con l'idea che il lavoro sia
espressione di noi stessi e sia il
nostro modo per realizzarsi e beh allora
avremmo miliardi di persone che tutte le
mattine si alzano per andare a portare
valore lì fuori e quindi verrebbe
naturale la collaborazione l'aiutarsi
creare cose belle il rinascimento
italiano questo l'ha insegnato molto
bene e poi il valore anche monetario e
quello che ti viene riconosciuto in
conseguenza
e allora bene però la domanda che tutti
mi fanno normalmente quando si affronta
questo argomento è e quindi come faccio
a identificare uno scopo e magari
inserirlo nel lavoro messo giù un
processo in quattro parti la chiamo la
piramide dello scopo lucky rambla per la
piramide del significato il livello base
la vocazione che cos'è la vocazione la
vocazione ce l'abbiamo tutti e la
chiamata che la vita ci fa il ruolo che
abbiamo sempre avuto alcuni lo chiamano
il tuo perché io per esempio da
piccolino i miei erano separati
mamma mi chiedeva sempre mi coinvolgeva
nelle decisioni di casa perché ero
l'uomo di casa questo cosa ha fatto a
cosa prodotto a prodotto che io in
qualche modo mi sentissi sempre un po
leader nelle situazioni e avessi lo
svilupparsi una propensione ad aiutare
gli altri a prendere decisioni poi
d'estate andavo da papà che viveva negli
stati uniti e questo cosa ha prodotto in
me
visione internazionale delle cose magari
anticipare un pochettino i tempi
riportando in italia quello che vedevo
durante le mie estati scolastiche.la
ecco la vocazione ce l'abbiamo tutti la
nostra storia
magari siamo il fratello maggiore e in
qualche modo abbiamo imparato ad
occuparci dei più piccolini quella è una
vocazione
sulla vocazione
la vocazione la posso usare in mille
modi diversi
devo poi decidere che come usarla come
faccio a deciderlo andando a prendere i
talenti allora qua sui talenti si apre
un mondo gigantesco è la cosa più
difficile anche iniziare a trovare una
definizione di talento ne ho scelta una
di un'esperta
riconosciuta per veramente a livello
internazionale
beppe ha detto il talento e ciò che ti
piace fare e che ti riesce bene e trovo
che sia una definizione tra l'altro le
possiamo dar credito perché è un
maialino felice e la felicità e proprio
espressione di vocazione di talento
quindi mettiamo queste due cose insieme
la tua vocazione la tua storia il
talento e quello che veramente ti piace
fare scuola anni 80 era un piccolo nerd
a nove anni ho iniziato a programmare
con i primi computer che sono arrivati
in italia a scuola lo sapevano
io spesso ci avevo la bolla al naso sul
banco di scuola perché mi annoiavo un
pochino un mattino entra il professore
di matematica e mi punta e mi dice dario
alzati e vai a scrivere il programma per
gestire la libreria di scuola alla
biblioteca di scuola perché ci serve
sarebbe importante per noi come
istituzione averlo
beh mi son sentito prima di tutto un
supereroe
secondo un supereroe con
un superpotere il mio super potere del
talento di programmare i computer ma non
solo per la prima volta ottenuto
riconoscimento sociale
sapete i nerd a a scuola non è che sono
prettamente considerati i sex symbol
della classe e
e in qualche modo in quel momento invece
avevo tutti gli occhi addosso e quindi
sono uscito tutto orgoglioso andare a
fare questa cosa quando metti insieme
queste due cose e decidi che cosa ne fai
nasce l'impatto cioè nasce la
conseguenza cosa del tuo talento della
tua vocazione a chi serve chi puoi
aiutare cosa puoi farne io per esempio
di quella roba lì ha deciso di fare
l'informatico originale direte voi beh
negli anni al fine anni 80 era già
ancora bayern ha ancora abbastanza
originale e ho fatto una cosa ancora più
originale perché dovevo mettere insieme
appunto talento ma anche la vocazione
quindi aiutare gli altri a prendere
decisioni il portare l'internazionale vi
ricordate quello che vi ho detto della
vocazione e cosa ho fatto stava
arrivando dagli stati uniti una cosa che
gli italiani conoscevano poco
una roba che avrebbe cambiato il mondo e
io andavo nelle aziende ad aiutarli ad
aa ad acquisire questa mentalità a
fargli capire che quella roba gli
avrebbe cambiato il modo di lavorare per
un po di anni ho portato internet nelle
aziende in trenta i tempi in cui non so
se vi ricordate ci si collegava faceva
pipì ecco quella roba lì andava a farla
tutti i giorni nel negli uffici quando
tu giorno dopo giorno
metti talento e vocazione al servizio di
un qualcosa fai un passino avanti tutti
i giorni tutti i giorni tutti i giorni
la somma di questi pasini genera
quello che tutti definiscono la visan la
visione la tua visione del futuro non è
che si crea semplicemente perché ci
credi
crederci importante ma quello succede
niente la vision si realizza perché
tutti i giorni e c e compì un passino
della tua missione
i primi tre elementi sono la mission
cioè la tua missione nel mondo e la tua
missione sostiene la visione e la
visione protegge la tua missione questa
è la piramide dello scopo è la piramide
del significato vedete stiamo per
diventare una specie
interplanetaria
noi forse no i nostri figli forse ma i
nostri nipoti certamente potranno
viaggiare sulla luna su marte in orbita
ci sta non serata sushi in orbita poi si
torna
questo cambierà tutto questo cambierà
tutto cambierà il modo di vedere le cose
i valori le abitudine la prospettiva che
abbiamo sul mondo e l'abbiamo già
vissuto come specie perché quando
l'europa ha scoperto il nuovo mondo è
cambiato tutto oggi mangiamo le patate
arrivano da quei grandi viaggi non oso
immaginare cosa arriverà da marte ma
questo è quello che succederà
e allora dobbiamo vincerla questa grande
sfida non possiamo continuare ad alzarci
tutte le mattine ad andare a procacciare
denaro
dobbiamo mettere i nostri talenti al
servizio dell'umanità al servizio di un
qualcosa questo farà la grande
differenza e quando io penso a leonardo
penso al rinascimento e penso
all'umanesimo e l'umanesimo però deve
essere questo perché quello che
distingue l'essere umano è proprio
questo il fatto che è capace a dare
significato e portar scopo nelle cose e
quindi diventiamo veramente esseri umani
grazie
[Applauso]